[Music]
welcome back everybody to another great
episode of the careful boys featuring
the careful boys here love being careful
we're gonna do something fun and
exciting and uh we're gonna go ahead and
get up out of these seats right here so
your main men can sit at this table
right here let's go ahead and bring bart
and joe up to the table
hey
cheers everyone
hopefully get into the truth of this
business the truth is it true all right
this is a good scene i never sat here
i've never sat here not bad i think i've
sat in every chair in the room it's
pretty it's it's
an awesome
2021 baby yep it's a new era new era you
know
for a long time people believed that jk
news
was 2 sjw
we're covering the topics that are just
way too damn welcome right and at other
times we'll be accused of being way too
damn alright well what is it then we're
both [ __ ]
we believe okay now this is this what
represents
america better than this yeah war
the idea that they're wearing both hats
and jab boxes and kindred shirts is
killing me right now worlds are
colliding
right now
that's like a tight dude they're not
respective beliefs by the way
over the years you know we've been
accused of many things yeah 2022 we want
to take our identity back all right like
i want to address all the [ __ ] all the
drama all the [ __ ] but also thank
all of the viewers that stuck with us
you know we are the cockroaches of
youtube and you guys are welcome here
you know because cockroaches welcome
everybody we are like the underground
people of las vegas or the skid row
members the mole people thank you it's
an honor thank you it's such an honor
thank you this is the place where
entertainers either come to be lifted up
and leave us
or this is the place where entertainers
come have fallen to and die
to be snack stagnant sideways and slowly
together yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah very
nice right not just in front of you too
what are some of the
things you would like to talk about
you're the host
he just gave a list so i was like okay
i would like to hear him
elaborately finally
you know like uh we had some fallen
soldiers
you know i'm not i'm not gonna sugarcoat
this right we we have some fallen
soldiers right like um and i'm not gonna
act like they fell
you know i'm gonna act like i'm gonna
tell you the truth you know i [ __ ]
booted the [ __ ] out of people
you know some people
they left on their own terms
others
i don't know you know like it just [ __ ]
happened i'm never gonna address it no
you didn't i'm gonna cut that right
there no sorry joe's a nice guy he's
he's a very very very very magnanimous
very very charismatic a very strong
personality on the tube when the
camera's on i gotta say that and that's
why i respect and love them yeah but bar
and joe are some of the nicest dudes and
you know i think that they've always
made decisions i'm interrupting you but
they've always made decisions and calls
for the best of other people and for the
for the community why you gotta have my
back like that my bad they're dicks we
second that i'm second this as well you
know i like being the villain and i like
being the dumbass my bad he booted some
people tooted and booted
but what i'm getting to is that you know
like i you know like
at the end of the day like um you know
it's it's it's always been like i just
want to be here to [ __ ] crack jokes
make fun have fun with everybody right
and then the thing is like
2021 was wild like we didn't know the
pandemic was going to continue happening
all this crazy [ __ ] and like when we
started filming again the [ __ ]
everyone was afraid of rona when you
guys came together were like yo let's
get rona together you know it was so
[ __ ] cool
yeah i think bart and steve literally
said i remember i remember saying one
time because i got the rona mid-2021 and
these guys literally like you can
[ __ ] come here and spit in my spit in
my mouth i'll [ __ ]
swallow it yeah and then i'll show you
my tongue oh i saw it
and i i i just i'm just i'm just
grateful that like this
group right here
is is like
maintaining with me and um not only is
this like fun to do i'm having much more
fun than i ever did before in a very
long time yeah yeah i think it feels
really good because you know when we
first did jk news like the whole start
of it it was after our jk film shoots or
jk party shoots we would just hang out
in the parking lot and [ __ ] around
and it would be like let's say we
finished shooting during lunch
and we would keep [ __ ] around in the
parking lot just talking [ __ ] and then
we look at the time we're like oh [ __ ]
it's time for dinner so i guess we'll
all go grab dinner like that's how how
quickly
time flew by and like oh [ __ ] we should
record this stuff
and so like that kind of parking lot
talk
you know like just through with the ups
and downs of how
sensor culture is and how comedy has
changed and all that so like even with
like you know different cast mates
it kind of the origin feeling and vibe
has gone through its own journey
and this is the closest
with you guys that has been to the
origin feelings of that parking lot
and if i may step in as the elder here
of the cast members uh because i think
i'm the oldest person here as far as
like who's been here consistently over
the years yeah yeah yeah uh yeah i
noticed that because like when i first
came oh yeah sure you came on 2013.
you came out
[Laughter]
[Music]
but no but it is cool because i remember
when i first came in and there was that
like where we're all hanging out
extracurricularly all the time and then
yeah i think you know cope it happened
and we all just obviously like just went
back to our respective homes for like
years like two years anyway and then now
it does feel more like especially with
this trip and all this stuff going on
like um it just feels like it used to
feel which is cool which is really cool
that's what i wanted to get back right
is that i think something happened over
the years where
comedy took this weird direction where
we were self-editing we were being like
oh [ __ ] should we do we say the right
thing or the wrong thing are we angering
people
you know and then like the whole thing
was we had to navigate and i was like
man we never had to do this [ __ ] we
could be authentically who we were and
then now people understood who we were
too
that's another thing but
going back to like how grateful i am
to being back to that original state
where we can like crack jokes and and
then basically the people that are you
know here with us that are still
watching they like this content so then
it's almost like we could go back to
what we originally wanted to do in the
first place and like you know talk about
these topics and be funny and like
be true i think that's the ultimate
thing is like man there was a time where
i was like i want to say something but
i'm scared because if i say this what
are the consequences that's gonna happen
to my friends you know our company all
this [ __ ] and we're not even saying
things that are that dangerous
and it's in the name
just kidding news
and it's cool that everyone here like
has each other's back and i feel like if
we were to be like a band i think we
were just like some guy would play a
chord and everyone knows how to play
along
so i'm really grateful for all you guys
youtube brother yeah appreciate you in
all honesty all you guys i love hanging
out with all you guys um even this guy
somehow it's crazy
the funny thing is
this is the funny thing right on camera
right like people really think that
steve bullies the [ __ ] out of anthony uh
he kind of does he does
for the cameras but but
which is a lot of the time that i'm with
them
but they hang out the most yeah like you
guys been [ __ ] bed buddies for like a
whole two weeks i don't know what you're
talking about okay don't tell them that
stuff man come on man you're off cameras
for a reason you're gonna live it
together for you know what i mean like
so like a high key don't like this guy
hi he even started using his words dude
i've had fans like in the dms
asking me
please like control this have like
control steve he's like bullying anthony
it makes me uncomfortable i'm like
are you [ __ ] kidding me bro like how
does that make you feel anthony
thank you to the fans
no [ __ ] you you know why because that
means dude you don't know true friends i
think true friends can exist when you
sound the [ __ ] out of each other because
you know where you guys are coming from
yeah yeah right it comes out of true
love and that's where and
if anthony really had a problem he
wouldn't be here the next take and the
next take and the next take and that's
what true friends is and this fool's
[ __ ] i don't even know what to call
him i kind of use any of these words
that's 2020 i call this dude
i call this dude fat [ __ ] for four years
straight when he was like getting
stronger and actually losing weight and
getting more ripped
so oh so you're using you're using
opposite disses
you're using opposite distance so it's
clear that it's it's a joke you guys are
using truths against me you [ __ ]
opposite we use opposite all time i
don't know i love i'm gonna i'm gonna
add on to that i really um what's what's
interesting for me is uh even though i
only came here six times in the last
seven years yeah yeah seven years
thinking there was there was a
consistency and a feeling that i always
had here which is why i always like
really love and appreciate being here
and stuff and it's that you know for me
for people who knew me before like um
most people on social media get to
receive like my artistic and my dance
side and i just happen to be that type
of like gemini with different
personalities where like when i create
and i dance it always ends up being like
a little bit serious or a little bit
more like you know ethereal because
that's the only way i can express myself
in that way because when i'm not dancing
i don't know how to express some of
those feelings and jk always kind of
gave me a place to do and express myself
in an honest way that wasn't through
dance i had a voice i felt i honestly
felt like i was given a voice here
it was just a guest or a host or
whatever position i like got to talk i
literally got to just
share thoughts on things express my
opinions you know really just get to
meet new people that i never would have
met that aren't from like the dance
community and stuff and that's what i i
really received from you and and those
things are invaluable so to be even here
in now 2022 because last year was the
first year that i i got to finally kind
of become a regular you know things
covered in its own blessings like you
parked me at home i couldn't fly on
travel and dance and do [ __ ] anymore so
i was like
[ __ ] i might as well go on jk news more
i'm more available and yet that ended up
being like if i didn't have jk news
especially last year like i honestly had
have no idea what i would be doing i
would still be scrambling to figure out
how to like fix the things and the
problems that have occurred during the
pandemic that were uncontrollable but
like jk just kind of gave me
not even an escape but just like another
home so i really appreciate that
proactive about it too though like
there'll be times where i'm like i'm
like hitting you up maybe like once a
month or something and you're like hey
you know what the next three weeks i'm
actually here like let me know i'm like
so i really appreciate that i love it i
feel bad because his announcement video
of we have a new host had the [ __ ]
drama of the century
it was the one of the most hated [ __ ]
yo i i really
do
i rarely read the comments and then it
was like oh she was my first time
posting so i was like i should check out
the comments how am i doing
no i was [ __ ] blown dude all the oh
[ __ ] yeah i don't know
everybody loves you dude it's so easy
it's so that's why we pile on you dude
because if you weren't cool and if you
weren't all sexy and a sex hacker and
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah if you said all this
[ __ ] it'd be bullying yeah it'd be
bullying so we can't it's too cool yeah
but instead we're punching up yeah we're
punching up dude it's all super fun
you know
he's like he can empathize with the
stripper because he's more than just a
pretty face with a nice body that knows
how to move exactly he has thoughts and
he has opinions
the the actual best thing about it is
that
is that
ryan anime isn't as a dancer we'll never
bring it up
we never talk about arguably the best
dancer we have one dancer in the room
there's one dance in the room
and we never bring it up ever great
bridge i'm very happy that ryan's here
now i gotta [ __ ] that dude ryan's always
been one of the [ __ ] coolest dudes
and it's just so crazy that he has such
a close connection to you guys separate
from anything that i've known about him
through dance and stuff and he just
[ __ ] knows everything from sgv you
guys history you guys [ __ ] church
colt thing that you guys are a part of
that i found that out on jk news that
they went to the same school i didn't
know he was the same [ __ ] guy oh did
you know that they went to the same
[ __ ] school i knew they went to
school but that's what you found out on
news
while we were sitting at the tables like
this
today's video is brought to you by feels
cbd is not about what you feel it's
about what you do not feel such as oh i
feel stressed or like oh i hurt my pain
my shoulder oh and
anxiety
and the part of what you don't feel is
so true
recently i've had this like big ass
knock on my back have you ever had that
before it's like over here oh yeah and
you're just like you're kind of like
this yeah like you know when like you
have a big brother chasing you and he
[ __ ] punches you in the back and you
do like that yeah yeah like it's to the
point where i move my neck up and down
and i can still feel it and i have a
really good physical therapist but she's
super busy so in between it's enough
where it affects my sleep and what sucks
is you're in the cat2 position because
if you don't sleep you also don't
recover fast and if you don't recover
it's gonna stay there it hurts more
hurts more so what was cool about having
some feels put a couple drops underneath
my tongue drink a nice little warm tea
have a nice little bedtime routine and i
was able to relax way more and i think
my natural like body like tensing
posture kind of relax and it has been
helping my back a little bit in the
meantime before i get to see my physical
therapist so i'm super happy that i got
feels and i brought it with me over here
and it's super easy to use you get a
couple of drops put in your tongue and
you can start to feel the chill effects
and if this is your first time tampering
and playing around with something called
a cbd and you're not sure it's a little
bit scary
no worries they have a hotline that you
can call and be like hey you know what
it's kind of embarrassing but not really
i never use this stuff and i and i'm
scared oh i don't know if i want to take
a bunch or a little i don't know what's
right for me can you guide me and
they'll be like yeah that's what we're
here for it's pretty cool yeah and they
also got this monthly membership so if
you're going to take it on the regular
you get to save a little bit of money
and it takes away the hassle of having
to order every single month so make sure
you go to fields.com that's f e a l s
dot com off the record to get 50 percent
off plus free shipping that's fields.com
off the record to get 50 off plus free
shipping yeah so we have mutual friends
and i'm like oh that's cool and he goes
wait and you made this connection you're
the guy you're joe mama or joe mama yeah
but then for it it was really funny
because i was talking about people and i
mentioned joe mama and he goes oh you
knew that guy
he's trying to slice something like try
to test me and i was like i didn't i he
was just like had a reputation that
followed and i heard you because it was
a legend but he's like what did you hear
about this guy
like he stuck his own dick in the
bathroom
yeah that's your mama that's that's your
mama yeah you heard him
when he said i'm him i'm joe mama like
my world just [ __ ]
[Music]
like
i don't think i'll be i'll ever be able
to explain how notorious that he was in
my high school like it's so weird yeah
trouble for something so cool dude joe
you gotta train the new yo joe mama yeah
at that school mama
i gotta tag that on the wall there's a
boy without direction out there who
needs he needs a mentor
yeah that tripped me up but i mean aside
from that the fact that i'd known both
of them for so long and didn't know that
i knew of him like just as a different
person was trippy i used to back in the
day like because i always viewed uh bart
and joe as like we were allies in that
generation of like asian independent
entertainment and we were like working
together to like make this wave like
work out
and then anytime that they were like hey
come on in jk or do a sketch i was
always like dude i wish i could do more
of these but i didn't want to [ __ ]
vlog he didn't say anything because i
didn't want i didn't i don't want to be
that guy that's like i was that guy
i think i'll be like hey i want to do
more of this stuff
you have like a
ceo personality you're a go-getter
i'm more of like a shy like hey i'll
move i've never said no obviously like
any time he's like i'm not busy yeah
he's been all coy but i've always wanted
to like just be around just for the fun
of it one of the oldest sketches we did
was that like a jk films like suicide
pill thing yeah yeah that was nuts you
know how many people didn't want to
[ __ ] do it
you were the 14th person they called i'm
glad i was there for the suicide pill
[ __ ] about [ __ ]
you know
making fun of suicide basically but at
the end of it it was like a psa because
he was just like yo dude just reach out
like we you know but then like people
heard of it like hello people were like
i'm [ __ ] touching this with a [ __ ]
temple pool dude
i don't even remember this [ __ ] but i
would have to say though the crazy ideas
that we've had
there were so many cool people that were
just like let's do it let's [ __ ] do
it dude yeah
yeah years ago was that that was 2009.
god dang i think this is our 15th year
on youtube maybe even 16th started in
2007 and then i think maybe 2000 yeah
probably 2009 to
2011 or 12 were super like we were
getting after sketches like crazy and
that's that's what was like the coolest
thing was just being around and hanging
out and just chilling and then i [ __ ]
came and saw this guy steve green and
i'm like when i met you i like i think i
told you like dude i've seen your videos
that stuff and you were so nice and i
was like i thought that dude was gonna
[ __ ] roast me or like bully me or
something
such a nice guy yeah i'm not because
when i met him i was like dude he's got
a [ __ ] legend that's so cool
you know what i like about like just
this this whole vibe is that everything
is like organic right like you have a
lot of groups out there that are
industry chosen or like kind of
manufactured as a company at the end of
the day
it's a it's it's a ticket like it's a
it's it's it's a paycheck
like yeah you guys get paychecks or
whatever but there's a lot of things
that you don't [ __ ] have to do or we
don't have to do like film here at the
trump tower
we're burning a lot of [ __ ] dumb
money like you know me but like it's
like let's do it dude let's have fun and
then
and then i think in the past too if it
maybe it wasn't the best way but i had a
lot of fun doing it it's just like
organically picking people and like
slowly like building true relationships
and then then when you have these
conversations they're much more
authentic and then they're much more
real and they don't feel forced like a
like a fake talk show or anything like
that and i think capturing that and
giving that to the audience is like the
best [ __ ] ever well i think it's like
bart said because i really i mean
i've spent so much time with you guys
over the years that like i really can't
tell when bart's about to finish a point
and when you're about to pick something
up and like it's it's a great little
thing that we have and like i feel like
i mean do we i know we have that right
like i like and i even even ryan like i
know
i can i can i can pick i mean you you i
was just saying this to anthony this
morning on our drive in today i was like
man it's funny when ryan opens up i'm
always like oh [ __ ] like my ears just
like perk up and i'm like okay whoa
because you're like a deep dude
um but you don't always just give us
that you you you kind of
pick your shots you ain't you aim for
like what you want to um come across as
which is great but yeah and and he was
like oh so i'm not that deep and i'm
like hey
it's not me
i'm used to it because i i see this guy
like every [ __ ] day
and so it's it's still remarkable
especially when you two open up because
i'm like i'm not as used to you guys
opening up which is great
technically we said we're still not used
to nick opening up he's the [ __ ] best
deflector in the whole he's the best
what are you talking about
what do you what do you mean like
deflect what do you guys want to know i
told you guys everything your
what does that mean look what does that
mean i tell you guys everything you want
to hear hey no you have been a better
boy about opening up yes
to give you credit but it's just it's
just entertaining to see the dynamic and
how the dynamic i
really like about the group here too
kind of touching upon what steve is
saying is
everyone
is kind of like a legend
but no one sucks their own dick ever
right like nick beats people up but he
never talks about our [ __ ] people up we
got two sick ass [ __ ] dancers that
never go like oh we're on [ __ ] tv
steve's [ __ ] legend and comedy no one
ever refers to themselves as the stuff
that they do youtube comedy youtube
comedy but it's just like i think people
like but you got videos that are like
200 million views 226 million people
that have crushed it
in their in their field yeah and um and
you're here to to join us at this bonus
talk [ __ ] this boneyard
but that's what i told nikki the first
time i was driving away from doing jk i
was like you know i could do that every
[ __ ] week and i didn't always say
that you know you do collabs on youtube
it's hit and miss you don't know what
you're going to get you guys all know
when you show up you're just like we'll
see how this goes i don't know how you
actually are in real life and then like
sometimes it's great sometimes it's not
but with these guys i was like dude this
is just like an old friend group and i
can tell like it's you can tell
everyone's real friends and stuff so
it's been it's been awesome man i'm
really thankful for this place this
place gave me because you know my
channel got demonetized and [ __ ] nobody
cares nobody's sad for me but the point
is is that the the best part of it is
that i had a place to go right i had a
place to go where i could still go and
it made sense to come to and you guys
gave me that and i i've always said to
these guys privately and on camera i
always want to defend this place like
especially like like the room like
because i what you guys made with this
particular room is just so free and like
everyone can come here and just be
themselves and yeah we all take shots at
each other and [ __ ] but it's all it's
all [ __ ] frankly it's all just you
know we're just we're just playing a
game
we cut and then we all laugh our asses
off and then you know this guy cries
and we laugh even more
and when he says this room he means
conceptually not this trump room we're
talking about the trump suite 6202
come here next time put your hand on the
wall we were here anthony please let him
roast you because that's the only way
he's going to stay with us i don't have
a [ __ ] choice he needs a pinata let
alone i got it i gotta say he says this
all the time too which is also really
[ __ ] funny i would not have ever
guessed that i would have met a friend
like steve which literally i met him
last year in 2021 because of jk yeah and
at first it was kind of like oh you like
crypto i like crypto too and now it
turns out he's like the dude that i've
like talked to and zoomed with like the
most all year yeah wow literally we
[ __ ] talk to each other the most yeah
i'm trying to do more of the spot
but nikki
like you know he comes off as this bully
and [ __ ] anthony hater he is a bully
actually the closest
i love him but he's still a bully and i
need you guys to keep dming joe
specifically
and [ __ ] put your foot down and don't
let this bullying happening and i'm like
you guys say that for me
that's it
you got
a [ __ ] full-grown adult he could
stand up for himself he's a dancer
doesn't mean he can't stand up for
himself yeah
he could pop a lot for himself he could
[ __ ] don't say your roly-poly for
himself holy bully
if anthony was fed up okay
the mashed potatoes let's turn about me
again signature moves
cause to be honest right like
if anthony was fed up he would
challenge steve go head to head and he
would get crushed we know who would win
that's true that's true that's why
there's there's no there's no rush to
get the [ __ ] out of here dude i'll
probably just leave red bulls everywhere
and he [ __ ] get confused i think i
pick everyone up and i drink them
all the way off a cliff
i want to see that
i want to i want this to be like a
[ __ ] fast and furious situation but
like a dance-off right like you call out
steve you're sick of his [ __ ] right and
you both
show up [ __ ] cars girls everything
ready and you guys have a dance-off to
settle oh wait actual real story wait
wait actually you met mike's song in the
dance can we talk for another video can
we talk about that i think i've already
talked about it here it's so [ __ ]
funny though because i can't believe
it's right i finally explained to him
how i met my song this morning oh yeah
dude that's the best story it's so crazy
jesus i can't believe that's real [ __ ]
it's saying okay yeah come on gonna give
you guys
this is a great special yeah this is
really good okay the point is all right
so um it's like 2004 i'm going to a
freshman orientation incoming freshmen
have a student orientation at uci right
um so before the school year starts
everybody goes there's a three-day
weekend and on the last day after you
know a bunch of people like teach you
about like school scheduling this and
that different clubs last night there's
like a dance but not everybody's a
dancer and it's against 2004 i i not
learned dance yet really i didn't start
dancing until college however sea
walking was the thing that i was in you
know it's for them gangsters you know
what i'm saying but obviously the
wankstar over here in me
i was such a [ __ ] loser but i really
wanted to [ __ ] learn how to see
walking do [ __ ] this is this end of the
[ __ ] program dance there's a circle i
get in because i'm trying to be i'm
trying to express myself i'm see walking
i'm i'm sure i look like a loser and i
get to [ __ ] tap on the shoulder i
turn around the angus korean i've ever
seen in my [ __ ] life he's going ham
on me right
and i've never met mike this is my song
i've never met him before but he's just
battling me i don't even understand
battle culture all i think to myself is
i'm not supposed to back down so even
though my dancing sucks i still go ham
obviously he's whipping my ass but then
while he hits
one of his rounds his shoe falls off
and again i've never been in a battle so
i don't know what to do i thought maybe
the
amicable and nice thing to do would be
to go pick up this guy's shoe for him
very nice however in a battle usually
it would be assumed that the opponent
would use that against the person right
so mike song with his wonderful
experience he looked at me and
foreshadowed that i would use the shoe
against him and my heart and in my
intention i was trying to realize him i
was like maybe i should show him that
we're together in this and i'll give him
that shoe as i go and reach over for a
shoe he runs over and he kicks his own
shoe outside
and i'm [ __ ] mind blown because i
wouldn't i had no idea how to humanly
react to somebody like kicking their own
[ __ ] out of the circle
and
he's in a dance battle circle yeah he
doesn't even know at the same time we're
people going oh
i don't know what they were owing at i
just had no idea i was just mind blown
like i was just going to give it to you
this guy for sure is going to be my
friend i don't know what that was but we
had a [ __ ] moment and that's the end
of the talk after like how did that
there's
one more thing he likes to constantly
bring up um there was a scavenger hunt
uh before the end of the orientation and
so
you're involved in the whackest [ __ ] all
the time
asian dance battles and then [ __ ]
scavenge [ __ ] easter egg hunts
you're involved in the black [ __ ]
anthony finish the story dude
it's really not as good
i i enjoy that joke more than the story
yeah i really don't know uh i like to
thank all of our viewers who stuck
around for so many years we love you
guys you know there's been many changes
i i i understand things might not be the
same but i can guarantee that with this
vibe and with this crew we're going to
give you some great [ __ ] for 2022. and
consider if you can
ryan is a dancer too i don't know i'll
take some considerate
i'll share it in the
yeah you can make fun of me we love you
all and and and just to formally say
thank you bart and joe there you go
thank you guys
[Applause]
[Music]
you